tous les mardis après l'école ces élèves
de la troisième à la sixième année se
rendent à la bibliothèque merci
ils ont rendez-vous avec le BDS freg
vous allez penser à illustrer votre
personnage principal de votre histoire
c'est aussi un rendez-vous avec leur
imaginaire
jongler avec la technique et leur
imaginaire pour être capable de faire le
personnage le plus percutant possible
alors on va tomber en amour avec ce
personnage là on va vouloir vivre ses
aventures
Frédéric Goyette qui signe les albums de
la bande à smaïki sous le nom de freg a
donné des cours de dessin aux jeunes qui
nous a appris
et
faire des
devises
[Musique]
ores des dessins pour m'améliorer parce
que là avant j'étais vraiment nul au
dessin après avoir un illustration
complète on essaie de voir les formes de
base de comprendre ces formes-là puis
après ça d'ajouter des petits détails
qui en ajouter de plus en plus et
l'écriture c'est la même chose j'ai fait
les bulles
improvisé au début je voulais toujours
de rebond mais ça le donne une sorte
d'araignée enfin je me suis dit je vais
le laisser comme ça fred est
particulièrement séduit par la
spontanéité des plus jeunes elles se
rend compte que il y avait un crocodile
juste derrière elle regarde d'abord une
tornade j'aime pas vraiment les dessins
mais j'aime partir
la dent de rencontrer l'auteur de se
faire expliquer comment ça fonctionne
avoir en plus la chance d'avoir des
cours de dessin fait que c'est aussi ça
a beaucoup c'est les a beaucoup motivés
c'est qu'un jeune super dynamique il y
en a parmi eux qui ont des difficultés à
l'école l'auteur ne leur cache pas les
difficultés qu'il a eu lui-même en
français à l'école je me reconnais en
eux et c'est la BD moi qui m'a qui m'a
sauvé si on peut dire
ma mère a eu l'intelligence des esprits
de dire la lecture avec du texte soutenu
c'est difficile pour toi alors je vais
te donner une bande dessinée personne de
ce moment-là j'ai su qu'est-ce que je
voulais faire dans la vie
cette activité parascolaire aura un
certain rayonnement et pourra en
inspirer d'autres dans cette capsule je
te montre des techniques pour pouvoir
dessiner des bras puisque les cours de
Fred feront l'objet de capsules diffusé
sur le site de Radio-Canada et pour ces
jeunes le résultat sera bien concret on
va avoir notre histoire en imprimé donc
ça va être comme si on était les vrais
hauteurs de cette histoire là ici
Anne-Louise despaty Radio-Canada
Montréal